una muestra de apoyo a ucrania varias
ciudades conmemoraron el aniversario 31
de la independencia de ucrania de la
unión soviética que coincide con el día
en que el país cumple seis meses en
guerra en bruselas lo celebraron
ondeando una gran bandera ucraniana en
la emblemática plaza grand place y
coreando eslóganes la presidenta de la
comisión europea dio palabras de apoyo
hay mucho que hacer pero podemos hacerlo
juntos europa está con ustedes hoy y a
largo plazo no honran en misa unas 350
personas marcharon durante más de una
hora a lo largo del famoso paseo
marítimo del prom en reino unido- la
banda de los guardias escoceses del
ejército británico interpretó un arreglo
de stefan ya la canción ganadora de
ucrania en el festival de eurovisión de
2022 en el vaticano el papá francisco
ofreció una misa al otro lado del mundo
en japon alzaron pancartas en los que se
leían mensajes pidiendo ayuda y apoyo
para ucrania
gestos que en medio de la guerra
emocionaron a los ucranianos
para mí ya sabes es simplemente
increíble porque es la voz del mundo no
sólo en apoyo de ucrania sino por la
libertad fueron libertad y por el
bienestar de todas las personas en todo
el mundo
los líderes mundiales también enviaron
sus mensajes al país europeo que desde
el pasado 24 de febrero sufre los
estragos de un conflicto que se ha
convertido en una guerra de desgaste y
en la que ucrania mantiene un 20 por
ciento de su territorio bajo ocupación
rusa